- [Voiceover] I thought
it would be interesting
to get a little bit more
intuition on ellipses
and their foci, or fo-si,
sometimes I like to
call them focuses, but
the correct word is foci
or fo-si, but either
pronunciation is apparently okay.
So let's work with this.
This is interactive
exercise on Khan Academy
as you see over here,
so let's see if we can
work through this together
and learn a little bit
more about ellipses.
So they tell us the
equation of an ellipse is
X minus X one squared over A squared
plus Y minus one squared
over B squared equals one.
And this is true.
This is the equation of an ellipse.
This would be an ellipse that
is centered at X equals X one,
Y equals Y one.
The major radius would be A,
the minor radius would be B.
So then they say find the
foci of the ellipse bellow
by moving the orange points
to their correct positions.
Then use that information
to find the values of
X one, Y one, A, and B.
So they want us to move these
to the correct position,
the correct position is where
the sum of the distance,
so if we move it to the correct position,
the sum of the length of that red line
and the length of that green line
should be constant.
Now you can see, they're clearly not
in the correct position right over here,
because up here when I
was moving it around,
you see that look, the
distance to focus one
from this point on the ellipse is 11.7,
that's the green line.
The distance to focus two is six.
You add them together, it's 17.8.
But when you move it around, that changes.
And so, we would have to find,
we would have to find a different,
we could just keep trying different foci
until that sum of these, the red length
and the green length is constant.
Now in my mind, that
is a hard way to do it.
An easier way to do it would be,
well let's figure out the
center of the ellipse first,
which we could do just literally
by inspecting this drawing,
and then figure out what the
length of the major radius
and the minus radius is
and then use that
information to find the foci.
So let's see if I can put these dots,
let me put them first at the center.
Alright, so let's see.
So that's center,
and let me,
that looks pretty good,
that looks like the center.
And I can even confirm.
So in the Y direction, that is
if I'm at the top of the ellipse I am
10 from that center and
if I'm at the bottom
of the ellipse, I'm 10 from that center.
And so that does look like the center.
And it also tells us, it tells us that the
major radius is 10
and it's along the y-axis.
So the major radius is 10
And we also know the Y
coordinate of the center,
it's Y is equal to four.
Y is equal to four.
And then the X coordinate of
the center is X equals five.
So once again, where
I put this orange dot,
that is the center of the ellipse.
It's at X equals five, Y equals four,
and that's why I put X equals five,
or X one equals five
and Y one equals four.
And you see from the equation of ellipse,
that's what defines the
center of the ellipse.
And then A is going to be,
A, we can see from here,
this is the radius in the X direction,
I guess is one way to think about it.
And that's gonna be the minor radius,
it's the shorter radius.
And you see that has length eight.
we're going from X equals
five to X equals 13.
Or X equals negative
three to X equals five.
So it has a length eight.
So this thing right over
here, A is going to be eight.
So this is eight.
And we already said,
the major radius is going to
be in the vertical direction
and it is of length 10.
So just like that we figured out
we could write the equation down,
I don't have my pen out,
but you could just say
this is the equation,
this ellipse is gonna be
X minus five squared over eight squared,
plus Y minus four squared
over 10 squared equals one.
But now let's actually figure out
where we need to put these,
where we need to actually put these foci
and then figure out that, hey look,
if we put them in the right place
the sum of the red and
green lines is going to be,
is going to be a constant.
And clearly where they are
right now it's not a constant.
You see that sum of the
distances is at 20.6
and then it goes to 20 point,
it's clearly not constant.
So let's see if we can do it.
And one way to do it is just to remember,
well there's a formula
and we talk about it,
we explore the intuition behind it
in a previous video,
but the formula for the foci ellipse
is you find the difference
between the larger
of these two values and the smaller
of these two values.
So in this case you'd find
the difference between
10 squared and eight squared.
Well that's going to be 100 minus 64,
which is 36, and then you
take the square root of that.
So it's going to be equal to six.
So the focal length is
going to be equal to six.
So if we go back to the center,
if you go back to the center,
if we had figured out
our focal length is six,
and remember, all I did is
I took the larger of these,
I squared it, and from that I subtracted
the other one squared.
So 100 squared minus eight squared is,
is 100 minus 64 which is 36
and I took the square
root of that to get six.
So our focal length along
the major axis, I could say,
is going to be six.
So it's going to be six from the center up
and six from the center down.
So six from the center up,
one, two, three,
four, five, six.
And six from the center down,
one, two, three,
four, five, six.
Now that's what the math tells us,
but let's just make sure
that this actually holds.
This actually holds.
So now let's go to points on the ellipse
and you see, it's calculating the distance
to each of the foci,
and the length of the
lines are the distances,
and you see when you sum them up
we are at a nice, constant 20,
which is the really cool
thing about ellipses.
That look, I can go anywhere around here
and the sum of these two distances,
of the green and the
red line, their lengths,
is a constant 20.
That's actually what defines an ellipse.
In fact, you can draw an
ellipse on a chalk board,
you could draw this
ellipse on a chalk board.
If you had a string of
say length 20 centimeters,
and you put one focus
there and one focus there
and you kind of put your
chalk in the string,
and you just tried to move it around,
and so it would look something,
it would look something like that.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that as fun as I did.